Hayden, particularly her proud
mother, Mrs.
Colleen Hayden who has lots of
reasons to be proud of her
daughter today.  In over 200
years ago, when the Library of
Congress was created, our
founders really charged the
joint committee of the library
and the librarian of Congress to
collect and curate a diverse
exilation lit ray warks for the
education and use of members of
Congress.  Even then they knew
that members of Congress didn't
know nearly all they
needed to
know.  When you really take any
time at all to look through the
Library of Congress's vast
collections or visit any of the
library reading rooms, you get a
sense of the importance that
our founders and those who
followed and placed on that
meeting that original mandate,
ensuring that our shared
cultural experience is preserved
and made available to future
generations through this
magnificent institution.
Anybody who has been here almost
always leaves saying this is
the unheralded jewel of the
Library of Congress, so
well-managed for so many years
by Mr. Billington who's here
today.  The library's first
collection was largely destroyed
during the war of 1812 was
replaced by purchasing tomentz
Jefferson's only personal
library.  From that relatively
small but big for the time
personal library, we've gone to
where it is now the world's
largest collection of books,
films, of sheet music, of sound
regardings.  This couldn't have
been accomplished without the
guidance of the nation's chief
librarians.  The first joint
committee on the
Library of Congress was ms the
first joint committee of
Congress and only 13 times
previous today have they been
able to witness the swearing in
of the librarian of Congress.
Each of those individuals
brought a unique perspective to
this position and took steps to
expand the library's collections
and how people all over the
world and people in our country
would share that collection.
The 13 previous librarians have
included a
poet, a political scientist, a
historian, two clerks of the
house, two lawyers and two
individuals who actually had
library experience.  In fact,
athe longest serving librarian
of Congress who became the
librarian at the turn of the
century and led the library
through World War I, the great
depression right up until the
eve of World War II had served
longer than anybody else had bin
a life-long library
administration.  I have no doubt
that our 14th liib rain, Dr.
Carla Hayden with her experience
in library management, will
further the work of her
predecessors and leave an
important mark of her own on the
Library of Congress and the
unique opportunity and challenge
the library faces at a time
where there is more
information, more accessible in
more ways than any of her
predecessors would think
possible.  It's an honor for all
of us to be here
with you today.
[ Applause ]
>> Librarian was really an
adventure to me to find out
there was a profession that was
dedicated to making books and
knowledge available to people
and that just seemed ideal.  The
conservation process really an
eye-opener for me because I got
to meet legislators that were
committed to not only the
nation's history, but making
information available and that
ways just a wonderful thing that
made me very pleased that I was
confirmed.  And my vision for
this library -- realize that
they have a national treasure
and that it is part of their
heritage and everyone can find
something in the Library of
Congress, produced by the
Library of Congress, that
relates to their lives what I
hope to accomplish with the
dedicated staff of the library
in the next 10 years of the
appointment is to really make
more of the collection
accessible.  And if we can say
that we have collections in the
next 10 years that have never
been -- around the country and
that people are going
[ Applause ]
welcome the speaker of the
United States house of
representatives, the
honorable Paul Ryan.
[ Applause ]
>> In 1815, as senator blunt
just mentioned, tomz Jefferson
sold most of his library to
Congress.  Partly because he was
a patriot, but mostly because
he was broke.  The British had
burned the original Library of
Congress when they invaded
Washington the year before, and
though a later fire destroyed
most of Jefferson's books, we
still have some of them.  They
make up the heart of the library
that we have here today.
Jefferson as you know was a
very, very unique man.  Other
people arranged their books
alphabetically or by size.  He
divided his library into three
sections that corresponded with
the three main faculties of the
mind:  Memory, reason and
imagination.  And when you stop
to think about it, those are the
very same qualities that define
Dr. Hayden.  First, as a
librarian herself, she has the
institutional memory necessary
to run the largest library in
the world.  That's a long way of
saying she's a pro.  She knows
what she's
doing.  Second, she understands
the need to bring the library
into the digital age.  We have
millions of documents that
almost knows a thing about.  It
would be a shame if they were
lost to the world out
of mere inconvenience.
It's that third quality.
Imagination.  That's what I
think is so important.  We all
think of America as this great
land of program  promise.  Where
people from all works of life
can get their start.  The public
library itself is the icon of
opportunity.  It's a safe haven
where people can go to learn and
to feed their imagination.  I
think of the writer James
Baldwin.  James Baldwin as a
young man would go to the
library and read his every book
he could get his hands on.
There he would be holding a
sibling in one arm and one book
in another.  What would have
happened to James Baldwin if
there had mind would have been
starved of its essential
material.  Nobody knows this
better than Dr.
Hayden.  She was widely praised
for keeping open her library
during Baltimore's unrest last
year, but for her it was the
only real choice, the obvious
things to do.  She seems to come
from really sturdy stock.  One
day when she told her mom she
was heading to the library right
in the middle of all the chaos,
all this trouble, her mother
replied oh, make sure you have
some coffee.  Our next librarian
is an accomplished woman and I
have every confidence she is
going to make us all very, very
proud.  Jefferson once said, I
cannot live without books.
Neither can we.  The Library of
Congress is our national
treasure, and with Dr. Hayden at
the helm, I know it is in
excellent
hands.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome the chief justice of the
United States, the honorable
John Roberts, to administer the
oath of office.  Please also
welcome Dr. Hayden's mother,
Mrs.
Colleen Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Please raise your right hand
and repeat after me.  I Carla
Hayden do solemnly swear.
>> I Carla Hayden do solemnly
swear.
>> I will support and defend the
constitution of the United
States.
>> That I will support and
defend the constitution of the
United States.
>> Against all enemies, foreign
and domestic.
>> That I will bear true faith
and allegiance to the same.
>> That I take this obligation
freely.
>> Without any mental
reservation or purpose of
evasion.
>> Without any mental
reservation or purpose or
evasion.
>> And that I will well and
faithfully discharge.
>> And I will well and
>> The duties of the office on
which I am about to enter.
>> The duties of the office
about which I am about to enter.
>> So help me God.
>> So help me God!
[Cheers
and applause].
>> Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome the senior senator of
Maryland, the honorable
.
>> >> Good morning, everybody.
I'm delighted to be here to have
the high honor, the privilege
of introducing Dr. Hayden to
you.
To make us proud, you all know
her you're ready to cheer her on
and you can hear from her.
Well, first of all, greetings to
all of you who have come from
Baltimore and from around the
nation.  Other professional
librarians and I want to
acknowledge that there are other
members of the Maryland
delegation that are
here.  We have all three
senators here.
And of course Nancy Pelosi.  We
know her heart is in little
Italy in many ways.  And Nancy,
I understand that after school
you used to go to the library
right on the -- am I correct
yes.
And so did
I.  Felt that access to
acknowledge and education would
be the key to the success of our
democracy.
That we would have public
schools for education and
inspiration.  Public
institutions, public schools in
public libraries.  It didn't
matter what zip code you were
born in, what was the income of
your family, you would have
access to a school, and you
would have access to a library.
Wow.  What a tremendous vision.
And here in our own country,
when the founders came and were
busy writing the constitution,
trying to decide what would be
the Missouri compromise, et
cetera, and they -- I'm sure
that the ladies who were also
encouraged to be included they
would ferment their own
resolution, encourage the
library.  Senator blunt gave our
history so well, and
Congressman and others have
spoken about Dr.
Hayden but know that the first
Library of Congress was directly
across from the old senate
chamber so that members of
Congress literally would caulk
-- could walk across the hall
and use the library.  We knew
that members of Congress didn't
know everything.  Write that one
down.  Wouldn't know
everything, but there would be
people who knew more, gave us
new ideas to lead this country
into its future and its destiny.
That's always been the spirit of
the library.  In all of
American history, only 14 have
served.
And first Dr. Hayden will be the
14th.  When I was called and
said the president was thinking
about nominated Carla Hayden to
be the next head of the Library
of Congress, what do you think?
I said wow!  That's like
bringing Cal Ripkin back to the
Orioles!  You couldn't do
better.  She has essentially
been peer reviewed by other
librarians and received numerous
awards and in Baltimore she
took over one of the
distinguished libraries and
working with her able board of
directors she helped number one
made it through creating
financial stability.  Making
sure that we maintain not only
the big downtown library, but
that we had branches open and
accessible in neighborhoods,
where families and children and
senior citizens needed to do it.
And along the way she also
brought it into the digital age
and now has got the effort with
her board and committee to raise
the money for the renovation.
She literally through working
with others in a collaborative
way, which I know she will be
here, she literally brought the
Onod prat into the 21st century.
She will do that here.  She's
an inspirational leader.  She
also knows that the library here
for the people.
Speaker Ryan talked about our
recent troubles and boy did we
have them during the up rising.
But when the schools were
closed, Dr. Hayden kept the
library open.  Right down to the
neighborhood we called ground
zero, one side of the street is
the CVS that had been burned
down.  Across the street was the
ENOT Pratt library branch that
was opened.  The lights kept
burning, open with light.  Ben
and I and others in the
delegation used that library to
have community meetings when the
second of education came, where
could we have our meetings
where people would feel
comfortable coming, it was at
the library.
And when you walked in that
library, during that time the
intention, there were kids
reading, there were people on
the computers trying to find
a job and to try -- what a
possibility could be.  She kept
it open.  A new innovation to
the library.  It's called
lawyers and libraries.  We pass
laws in Maryland criminal
justice reform.  There is the
possibility of getting your
criminal records streamlined and
because of errors in the whole
process.  In the neighborhood
where they -- which the one of
the hard scramble neighborhoods
in Baltimore.  On a Saturday
morning when lawyers and
libraries were introduced, 600
primarily men, all
African-American men, stood in
line to meet with a pro bono
lawyer or a paralegal to help
them work their record through
so they could reenter -- not
only reenter society, but get a
job in the job market.  As they
went through that process, 600.
At the end, they met with the
librarian who said hi, would you
like a library
card.  I hear that day, that men
who had been through a lot in
their life could not believe
they were given a library card.
Do you mean I can come here at
any time?  Yeah here is the
computers if you're going to be
looking for a job.  This is what
the library means?  The answer
was yes.  All of those
innovations came from Dr. Carla
Hayden.  And what does that mean
now to the Library of Congress?
We don't do programs like that.
You know what?  This library is
now in the process of
transforming itself.  Libraries
are redefining itself.  But what
we know is we go back to the
founding principles of our
country, public institutions
made available to the public for
their use to empower
themselves.
And I know that Dr. Hayden would
work very closely with the
Congress with some of the
reforms that are necessary and
some of the new transformational
ideas that she will bring.  I
feel President Obama made a
great choice in Dr. Hayden and
your mother Colleen, we want to
say hello to you, a teacher and
educator in her own right.  I
want you to know that the gift
from Baltimore, you've had a lot
of us, but the real gift will
be that Dr. Hayden will really
take this Library of Congress,
which will be, I will assure
you, as over the next days and
months become the Library of
Congress for the American
people.  Thank you and I'm going
to bring Dr. Hayden up so she
can tell
you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, senator Mikulsky
for your very kind introduction.
Your 39 years to the service of
the state of Maryland and to the
United States Congress is a
shining example of dedicated
public service.  I am also
extremely grateful for your
personal friendship.  It's meant
so much to me.  Mr. Speaker,
I'm honored by your remarks and
your presence here today, your
commitment to the nation and
public service and your respect
and admiration for this library
are so appreciated by the staff
and especially by me.  Mr.
Chiefjustice, there is no
greater distinction than to be
sworn in by you as librarian of
Congress.  I want to thank you
for your regard for this
institution and its role as a
source of knowledge and
information for the country.  I
would also like to acknowledge
the joint committee on the
library.  The oldest continuing
joint committee of the United
States Congress.  Your belief of
the library's mission builds on
the partnership between
Congress and this library.
Thank you so much for your
continued support.
Now, I must admit that it is
hard for me to imagine the
little eight-year-old girl with
pigtails who checked out a book
called bright April, over and
over and over again, until the
fines came in.  That she is
standing here today.  And it
feels like yesterday when I
began my career at a storefront
branch of the Chicago public
library and watched Judy Zucker
on the floor leading storytime
for children with autism.
Watching her interact with the
children and in turn seeing
their reactions demonstrated the
power and potential of a
librarian's work.  And 40 years
later, it is an honor to be
nominated by President Obama and
confirmed by the United States
senate to lead one of the
greatest institutions of our
nation.  I am truly grateful and
humbled by this selection.  Now
some people have noted that I
am making history as the first
woman, and the first
African-American in this post.
[Cheers and applause] and that
is true.  Library pioneer Dewey
often encouraged women to enter
the profession because they can,
quote, bear pain.
[ Laughter ]
And
could, quote, perform,
monotnous
tasks without boredem.
As a descent ebt for people who
were denied the right to read,
to now have the opportunity to
serve and lead the institution
that is the national symbol of
knowledge is a
historic moment.
[ Applause ]
So many people have been part of
my journey, family, friends and
colleagues, many of them here
today.  Too numerous to mention
by name, but I think all of you
for the life lessons you taught
me, all of which have shaped my
experience.  I do want to thank
my mother, who among many gifts
introduced me to reading, music
and public service.  It is very,
very special that she is here
today with me as I embark on a
new chapter that brings all of
those passions together.
[ Applause ]
To have her join me on stage and
hold the Bible that belonged to
Abraham Lincoln was a special
moment for us.  My family is
from Illinois.  And many of my
family members are buried in the
same cemetery as the 16th
president.  I want to thank the
United States Congress for
building and sustaining this
library.  I appreciate seeing so
many of you here today from
both houses and both parties.
This library is your library and
its service to Congress remains
the core function of the
institution.  The library is
also one of the greatest gifts
and legacies that Congress has
given to the American people.
The vision of the national
library to serve members of
Congress and the community they
represent continues the legacy
of my 13 predecessors.
Over time, these leaders have
expanded the scope of the
materials collected, advocated
successfully to bring the
federal copyright system here,
and one by one, overseeing
construction of the facilities
necessary to house and preserve
the collection and services
offered.  For over two
centuries, each librarian's
experiences and contributions
reflected the country's social
and historical landscape, and
all have advanced the progress
of the library.  The sixth
librarian of Congress famously
called it the book palace of the
American people.  When this
building opened in 1897.  The
Library of Congress is so much
more than beautiful architecture
wrapped around book shelves.
It is in fact a second part of
the quote, less often used, that
is truly powerful.  He called
it the book palace of the
American people in which you all
have equal rights with me, in
which the works of all of you
will be welcomed and forever
preserved.
The eighth librarian of Congress
described the library as a
service outside of the limits of
Washington, and it is indeed a
service to the country at large.
And the 13th librarian of
Congress believed whole
heartedly in this idea.  Dr.
James billington often talked
about getting the champagne out
of the bottle and he made
significant progress.
[ Applause ]
I am touched that he is here
today as librarian of Congress
emeritus with his wonderful
wife.  I want to thank you for
your graciousness, your service
and the strong legacy that you
created.  I would also like to
take a moment to acknowledge day
ofty librarian of
Congress David
>> And the senior staff
of the library --
[ Applause ]
Who are making my transition
into this post well-informed and
as smooth as it could be.  The
stewardship of this team on
behalf of the library is a
shining example of the human
assets our nation is so well
served by.  The staff of the
Library of Congress believed in
this institution and feels
honored to serve as I do.  Now
today, through the power of
technology, thousands around the
country are able to watch this
ceremony live.  This is an
opportunity to build on the
contributions of the libraries
who have come before, to realize
a continuing national library
vision that reaches beyond the
limits of Washington.  When I
contemplate the potential of
harnessing the power of
technology with the unparalleled
resources at the Library of
Congress, I am overwhelmed with
possibilities.  These resources
include more than 162 million
items on nearly 840 miles of
book shelves.  If you stretch
these book shelves from
Washington, D.C. along the
interstate system, you could
travel all the way to Davenport
Iowa before reaching the end.
This library holds some of the
largest collections from maps to
comic books, founding documents
like Thomas Jefferson's
handwritten draft of the
declaration of independence.
The full paper of 23 presence,
the works of Frederick Douglass,
thurgood
mar shal.  I am reminded of a
moment during the unrest in the
city of Baltimore in April of
2015, the Pennsylvania avenue
branch library was located in
the epicenter of those events.
But I made the decision to keep
the library open, to provide a
safe place for our citizens to
gather.  And I was there hand in
hand with the staff as we
opened the doors every morning.
Cars were still shouldering in
the streets, closed signs were
hanging in storefronts for
blocks, but people were lining
up outside the doors of the
library.  And I remember in
particular a young girl coming
up to me and ask, what's the
matter?  Why is everyone so
upset?  She came to the library
for sanctuary and understanding.
The Rosa parks collection, which
includes her family Bible, the
Bible she carried in her purse,
and her handwritten letters.  In
one such letter she reflects on
her December 1, 1955, arrest
writing quote.  I have been
pushed around all my life and
felt at this moment that I
couldn't take it anymore.  That
letter, and all of her papers,
are now digitized and available
online.  So anyone, anywhere,
can read her words in her own
handwriting.  They can read them
in the classrooms in Wisconsin,
in a small library on a
reservation in New Mexico, and
even in a library of a young
girl in Baltimore looking around
at her city was in turmoil.
That is a real public service.
And a natural step for this
nation's library.  A place where
you can touch history and
imagine your future.  This
Library of Congress, a historic
reference source for Congress,
an established place for
scholars, can also be a place
where we inspire young authors,
where we connect with those
individuals outside the limits
of Washington and help them make
history themselves.  How do we
accomplish this?  By building on
a legacy that depends so much
on the people in this room.  Not
only the elected officials, who
have quite a bit to say about
the direction of this
institution, but also the staff
of the Library of Congress.  My
new colleagues here on the
mezzanine, watching in the Adams
cafe, watching in Culpepper,
Virginia at the campus for audio
conservation and watching in
the national library services
for the blind and physically
handicapped.  Public service has
been such a motivating fact for
for me in my life and my
career.
When I received the call from
the White House about this
opportunity, they said, will you
serve.  And without hesitation
I said yes.  Throughout my
career, I've known that the
staff of the Library of Congress
is a dedicated and enthusiastic
group of public servants and I
look forward to working with all
of you for the years to come.
But we can't do it alone.  I am
calling on you, both who are
here in person and watching
virtually, that to have a truly
national library, an institution
of opportunity for all, is the
responsibility of all.  That
means collaborating with other
institutions; that means private
sector support, and patriot I
can philanthropy.  That means
starting a new dialogue about
connectivity to classrooms and
other libraries.  I cannot wait
to work with all of you to seize
this moment in history.  So
let's reach history at the
Library of Congress together.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome the chaplain and rise
for the benediction.
>> Before I pray, I want to pass
on the regrets of the senate
chaplain who was called away at
the last minutes and from my
regrets that I cannot replicate
the dull set tones of his mafl
lus voice.  Let us pray.  We
give you thanks, o God, for this
opportunity to celebrate the
swearing in of Dr. Carla Hayden
as the 14th librarian of
Congress.  It is an opportunity
for all present and for all of
the American people to reflect
upon the importance of this
greatest of institutions which
today is entrusted to her.  May
she be confident that her work
is a vital thread in the fabric
of our nation and appreciated by
those gathered her before all
Americans.  Bless Dr. Hayden and
dear God, bless the United